he
just came in awesome and he's talking to
the dog all cute
he sounds he seems terrible terrifying
i'm terrified i'm gonna go back to my
room
instead of being downstairs dressed like
a boy for easter
terrified anything
there he is and he's panting to himself
frustrated at his life he beats me he
knows that people know that he
beats me he's an alcoholic who never
leaves the house
he has all his own whiskey in this house
and liquor or whatever he drinks all
that stuff i can't even touch that stuff
because i have arthritis
psoriatic oh he also has arthritis
he also has arthritis
okay all right so everything right
i know you're saying that his name is
daytona hypernova but i don't think that
doesn't look like florida at least from
what i'm seeing outside
from the little tiny window
burp into himself he's burping to
himself
the dogs are following him because he
has several dogs
[Applause]
he's outside with [ __ ] kid what is
your problem
and it's really disturbing when you're
the person getting beat down
watching all this so they're all
i want to run this down and please
someone in the chat tell me if i've
missed this
he's
he gets beat by his brother he has
psoriasis that bleeds sometimes
he has arthritis
he's not moving out because of the kids
but he doesn't have money to cure his to
to take the medication for his arthritis
and this is his brothers and trump's
fault am i correct
yeah all right so this is
the video of him and his brother
fighting
insane [ __ ] brother shouting at me
at the right in a restaurant
all right here we go oh man this is this
is what we've stumbled the crown is
upon is amazing wow now he has 45 subs i
wonder who those people are
let's see
[Music]
outback steakhouse fan i thought you
said your brother never leaves the house
again remember his brother never leaves
the house
i mean she won't get very far because
there's too many um too many people out
there running
because like kasich is well he can't run
he's giving it up because he's been in
there too long
yeah he already one is this from this is
from 2017.
this is from 2017. this guy's been doing
this for a while for a couple years now
45
subs so they're talking about kasich
but that you said he's running
and um houston
mary taylor she's the one lieutenant
governor right now she's
running um let me think oh there's a
whole
oh my the wine yeah i think they had
he is in a different party though uh
he's
he's a republican the rest of them all
democrats
no yeah look at that they all seem like
they all seem insane folks
mary taylor she's lieutenant governor
she's probably republican
but i'm thinking about taylor wow look
at this guy look at this [ __ ]
vicious dude talking about kasich
[Music]
it's caused by stress he's showing his
psoriasis
it's caused by stress everything in
these people's heads
is everybody else's fault everything
their diseases the way they're treated
they
take no responsibility for anything
that's wrong
in their lives not one not an inkling
he's poor guarantee you he's not
grabbing the check with his blood hands
[Music]
people act different when they're on
camera i don't think this guy knows he's
being filmed
so many yeah remind you of the lineup
there's so many you ready yep i'm ready
let's go i want to run the same project
[Music]
what an [ __ ] that guy you see that
piece of [ __ ] that he is
you see what a piece of [ __ ] he is
saying that might be too big for the dog
you're right man you know what i'm
turning around
hello now he speaks to me after four
years live in the house where he beats
me
[Music]
whoa here comes the fight here comes the
fight here comes the fight let's hear
that again let's show that again
hold on here it comes here it comes here
we go here we go get ready
wow he speaks to me after four years
living in the house where he beats me
you beat us what did you just say
remember when you hit me in the eye and
gave me a black eye
this person this person
look at that look at that now we're
finding out who the little
violent queen is here huh now we're
finding out
who's a violent queen is she's this
person
you're helping me do what oh yeah
you could wrap that in a napkin no oh my
god just get over it
just leave it the dog doesn't need the
food that
it takes much according to sherman i hit
him in the eye at some point
tonight according to sherman i hit him
in the eye at some point yeah the police
came because you hit me in the eye and
gave me a black eye
remember when you came out of the room
and you start beating everybody
beating everybody now
he's beating ever look at this guy oh
we're figuring this out
i am so happy oh god this is such a deep
well
it's such a deep well
are thank you closer i'm with you your
parents are not young people stop making
their lives a [ __ ] hell
a lot of deep [ __ ] and by the way
brothers feud
all the time so stop acting like he beat
your [ __ ] little
confronted with the truth and he runs
exactly the moment they get didn't we
call the police when you came out of the
room and started beating everybody
wasn't that you
wasn't that wasn't that you that did
that that was you that did that right
and then all of a sudden he runs away oh
i'm so happy
here we go
[Music]
three of you are in so much deep [ __ ]
i'm sure i'm sure i mean you're just
gonna just pretend like it's not real
but it is
so much look at the mom's like yeah okay
i'm sure honey
okay honey yes we're in deep [ __ ] honey
you're right honey we're in deep [ __ ]
we're in we're in deep [ __ ] honey you're
right
you don't let a man beat another man not
not a man who trusts
just don't yes you do you don't let a
man
beat another man not a man who dresses
like
are you hearing this but they're not
crazy they're not crazy
they're calm and centered people
you don't let a bad man beat her first
off yeah you do you let dudes fight it
out it happens all the time unless the
weapons are involved they don't beat the
[ __ ] out of each other they get over i
have friends
who have been friends for 20 years and
are still friends who have had
fist fights beat the living [ __ ] out of
each other and our best friend still
today
so shut the [ __ ] up man up bucko
and he let it happen over and over and
over again and now he's saying i
hit him in the eye i've never touched
that man in the eye in my life
i've never done that he's gaslighting
that
gas lighting holy [ __ ] this guy's using
all the buzzwords
he's using all the buzzwords you ran
away
because your brother was right and
you're a little and now you don't want
to get caught
being a hypocrite he's crazy
and then he's wait a second wait a
second
oh no did i hold on never done that he's
gaslighting
what that license plate where's it from
i just want to see where they're from
it's not that's not a florida place he's
crazy and then he's
i mean he's just he's completely
unstable
he's talking about all these neighbors
who are so dangerous he beats someone in
his own house
um hold on table
he's talking about
pittsburgh pittsburgh steelers
is so this pennsylvania
is ohio ohio we got it it's ohio it's a
pittsburgh steelers fan
ohio wait no now someone's saying
pennsylvania ohio or pennsylvania who
is it all these neighbors who are so
dangerous he beats someone in his own
house
that you just let him live in
so it's ohio okay
oh it's not daytona hypernova it's
dayton hypernova i should have known
that i was saying daytona because i live
in florida
oh well good i'm glad actually it's not
a [ __ ] florida person
get a life the mom is not even putting
up with it because you're a
[ __ ] liar dude it's gonna go
somewhere mom
it's been two years because this is from
2017 and you're making videos now in
2019
you've done nothing in two years you
haven't called the cops
the guy hasn't been removed from the
house you've done nothing but made
videos
about yourself being a victim
i'm glad i humiliated hell yeah and he's
an alpha
older brother sits up front
yeah you do in public you always i'm
always in public with you every time i
have to pull you off a mom when you
verbally attack her i've never done any
of these things you have
you have to stop you i've had to pull
you off a mom how many times i've never
done these things
i've never laid my hand ow [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] the other side of the story
here we go the other side of the story
has come
out folks
sherman sherman no one's going to
believe you because you're an idiot an
[ __ ] you have a large fist that run
into
nobody's going to believe the guy who
seems to be
normal with kids
hanging out with his parents taking them
to outback
but they're going to believe you oh my
god
this is manna from heaven this has been
around forever
dayton hypernova is ours
don't let anybody take him from us
no he just said that don't even talk to
him
sherman i've beaten you mom have i
beaten you
well you get in my face i've never oh my
god i've never done what he just said
i have never done the mom look at them
well you do get in my face and scream
and stuff
what he just said tell everybody yelling
at you
okay i have reacted to mom reacting at
me that is
oh of course it's always somebody
else's fault it's always
somebody else's fault always
always always always it's always
somebody else it's
never your fault they're not your faults
you weird ass
sherman
she man the [ __ ] the most i've ever
done i've never
done any of these things that you are i
mean
the two two of the three times that you
have beaten me
two of the three hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on
okay set two
of the three so you better have a
brother if you ever i've had brothers
the amount of times that we get into
fights since we were kids up until the
adults it's got to be
20 to 30 times because that's what
brothers do they fight i'm not saying
fist fight and beat the [ __ ] but they
[ __ ] smack each other in the back of
the head and
what the [ __ ] bro nut check each other
all the time
so in your entire life being his brother
you say he's hit you three times in the
other videos
he makes it sound like an
epidemic he's making it
sound like an epidemic like
every day he comes home
hold on
i i i know exactly what uh
uh here it is
he's making it seem like this is what
happens
every time every time
he walks home
he's making it seem like this is what
happens
every single time he comes home thank
you thank you so much
back to the video hold that three times
you have beaten me oh my god i did this
and you're gonna
thank you feeling spare five bucks i
appreciate it but
[Laughter]
yes yes
what the [ __ ] dude are you serious
act like uh this is a symptom of
something before no sherman you are
three ties by
side sherman you're so when i hit you
it's fine
when i hit you it's okay it shouldn't
matter because in my mind i think i'm a
so it's fine
came out of your room and violently beat
me oh my god i'm so glad i had this on
video
showed up and you lied to him what the
police showed up
and they lied it by the way notice
something
the parents are not saying the parents
seem to be on older brother's side here
everything the parents seem to be on
older brother's side here this is
amazing
what did i say sherman what did i say oh
no sherman is the older brother we don't
know this guy's name this is dayton
hypernova came over and said oh i don't
want to talk to you anymore because
you're saying i
didn't even show up addie was over there
across the street with her husband
addie did not be able to go to sam i
want to go to sam's
this poor old lady's lived her entire
life worked really hard to provide for
her children
and all she wants to do is sam all she
wants to do is go to sam
and [ __ ] hypernova over here
can't allow it he can't allow them to
have a nice weekend
day together he won't allow it
no just live in your own world yes
sherman
yes
oh i'm sorry mom sure won't you go in
with me
i'm hurt
sherman the older brother why don't you
go in with me to get you away from him
holy [ __ ] if you would we would have
just watched his other videos
we'd be like well we don't know what was
really happening but this is now ground
zero of what's happening
crazy person that's less than half the
size that was me
i'm so violent no you've beaten me
it's a problem it's a problem
yes did you hear that the mom said yes
you did do that
um you don't mom i'm gonna ask you one
question one question only
did earl run out of his room yes in a
violent rage
and attack me and put you in the face
i've done that i've done that i've
punched sherman police and then you
called the police oh [ __ ]
earl the tree
what happened earl to your little
narrative
and by the way he still has this video
up he
still has this video up
he still has this
by me video broke your foot
kicking me you broke your foot
kicking me
what's wrong earl you also have bone
itis on top of the cirrhosis
yeah the [ __ ] you think bone evil
because you're brittle bird bones
and let me guess how is that trump's
fault
oh how's it evil trumpster's fault
[ __ ] loser i got beat down by you and
dad both
both of you had your fists and bodies on
me one or the other
dad was crushing me and you were beating
me
and that's why he comes out team sherman
team sherman all the [ __ ] way man
team sherman get it get it son
he's right and you don't like this
sounds exactly like also the videos
holy [ __ ] person he says
has a mental illness
laughs
[Music]
laughs
[Laughter]
uh
he's wearing mascara
non-con how do you not punch that
oh
oh oh [ __ ] man
oh no i have a mental illness while he's
beating me
he beats me and calls me a person look
at him
look at him look at the mascara
look at the mascara